sports
and the library
is just a creation being beaten precisely at an
educational institution in a kindergarten how many
destroyed schools kindergartens of
houses how many
simply not people
he and ruin my everyday life of our power
tonight our capture is full there is no
Russian aggression
explosive well the capture of light gives a removal of
his retinue where you shoved light into him
Kharkiv and the Kharkiv region were spent on them,
I think this is how our nation bears
such a rank of the ruble carcass of our children,
I don’t know
that there were our children, according to you,
at the beginning I didn’t know
until 9